hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear and happy Halloween now what I had
originally planned to do for my
Halloween video was to do kind of a
brief history of horror movies and I
actually did start working on that but
as Halloween approached I realized um
obviously it's a way bigger undertaking
than I imagined that it would be so I
didn't get it finished in time and I
want it to be good so I don't want to
rush it so I'm still going to do it but
I couldn't get it up in time for
Halloween so I apologize for that but I
will be putting that up uh in probably
like maybe a few weeks in the future
like after this video goes up so I was
just kind of like well I need something
that I can do fairly quickly like to put
up for a Halloween video and so I was
thinking well I'll just do another movie
review like another Halloween themed
movie however um I had already covered a
pretty significant number of the really
great Halloween movies the good
Halloween movies and the kind of fairly
decent Halloween movies like and I'm
talking more about movies that are
actually set on Halloween so I admit
that I was scrambling a little bit to
come up with something to review that I
hadn't talked about before either you
know with Tom or by myself so I kind of
toddled over to shudder and looked in
their little Halloween Horror section
which I think has like 26 movies in it
and and I was very pleased to spot a
1982 sort of Quasi slasher movie that I
actually never got around to seeing back
in the day it also had a cast uh
including the great Peter Jason uh
looking kind of young in this one and
had a bunch of extended cameos really
what amounted to Extended cameos by John
kerine who is in pretty much every movie
ever made uh Carrie Snodgrass who was in
Easy Rider she was in the fury she was
in a bunch of other stuff uh the great
Steve railsback uh who was in Helter
Skelter and of course life force the
Toby Hooper uh movie uh also has Paul
Bartell from eating Raul uh Katherine
Coulson the log lady from Twin Peaks and
John blle Danner from the Kung Fu Series
so like I said this has kind of a lot of
big names in it you know what I mean and
it's I'm actually amazed that I had
never got around to watching it so the
director of this movie is Gary Graver uh
he actually worked as a cinematographer
for no less than Orson well for Christ's
sake but uh also worked for kind of
schlock icons Al Adamson and Fred Olen
Ray um Gary Graver later on mostly known
for making porn I believe he made
roughly 150 pornographic films so
there's that now he funded this movie uh
trick-or treats from 1982 uh with about
50 grand out of his own pocket now this
movie is not to be confused with the
1986 movie called trick-or treat that
had jeene Simmons and Aussie Osborne in
it which probably I don't think I've
reviewed that one maybe I should do that
one one of these days or of course the
awesome 2015 Anthology movie which is
called Trick r Treat with just an r in
the middle with Sam in it you know what
I mean so this movie it's very apparent
when you watch it that uh that Gary
Graver was trying to make something like
akin to the real popular slasher movies
of the period like obviously this was
1982 so slashers were all the rage um so
this one has elements of Halloween
obviously uh and when a stranger calls
in particular but I have to say that
even though trick-or treats is you know
a pretty decent watch it's diverting
enough I guess I mean it doesn't come
anywhere close to approaching the
heights of either of those movies and I
think um to its detriment I think it
kind of tried to add in a little bit of
a dark comedy element that doesn't
really work all that well so at the
beginning of the movie you have this
character named Joan O'Keefe and she's
having breakfast on the patio with her
supposedly high-powered executive of a
husband whose name is Malcolm that's
Peter Jason by the way now he's just so
engrossed in his Wall Street Journal
that he's barely acknowledging her
existence he's got a suit on and
everything like that now shortly after
this there's a knock at the front door
and two men in white coats the standard
men in white coats uh who are holding a
straight jacket they you know are right
there on the doorstep so Joan quietly
lets them in and there's kind of this
extended sequence then where they
attempt and finally succeed in hauling
Malcolm off to an asylum like much to
his he's just screaming and struggling
and it's like actually like a pretty
funny scene like the fight and
everything now you see Joan kind of like
smirking and her attitude is like real
Blas about the whole thing so that leads
you to conclude that this whole thing is
her doing and that she's somehow been
able to convince some doctor somewhere
that her husband has to be locked away
in an asylum for his own safety and that
of others but obviously maybe it's it's
never really made clear but you're kind
of like well she just wants him out of
the way for whatever reason so the movie
then jumps ahead 4 years and Malcolm uh
is still in the psychiatric hospital and
is not real happy about it as you know
that's understandable I guess now Joan
meanwhile has remarried a dude named
Richard that's John carine's character
and they still live in the same house
that Jonah Malcolm lived in and they're
also uh looking after SL raising Jon and
Malcolm's really obnoxious pre-teen son
Christopher who's actually played by the
real son of the director Gary Graver
whose name is also Chris or Christopher
so Joan and Richard have gotten invited
to some fancy out of town Halloween
party that necessitates like flying
somewhere I don't know exactly where
they're going maybe Vegas did they say
it was Vegas now I can't even remember
so because they're going out of town
they hire a woman to babysit their brat
for the
night now the babysitter happens to be
this aspiring actress named Linda now
Linda is played by uh Jacqueline giru is
I think how you pronounce her last name
she was actually married to Steve
railsback at the time so she gets called
in like in real life obviously so she
gets called into the job at the last
minute so this makes her have to bail on
her boyfriend Brett who's played by
Steve railsback uh he was doing like his
opening night performance of a fellow
and so he gets really me pissed off like
because like you were supposed to be
here like front Rosie it's my opening
night it's my big debut blahy blah she's
like look bro it's like I have to work
or the agency's going to fire me so you
know there's that whole thing so they
have this whole argument about that now
on that like to that end I'm not really
sure why the movie had this whole kind
of sub I don't know if I'd call it a
subplot but it's definitely they return
to it over and over again about Linda
and Brett like kind of over the course
of night like calling each other and
talking about oh hey how's that aell
performance going and he's like yeah
how's it going with you and blahy blah
because it ends up not really factoring
into the plot at all other than
providing a couple of like misdirects
like about phone calls because this has
like a little bit of a Prank Caller
element to it as well much like when a
stranger calls like I said um but you
know whatever so this was this was kind
of a thing and I'll get more into this
in a little bit but there's a lot of
stuff in this movie that doesn't really
factor into the main plot and probably
didn't need to be in there it just
seemed a little Superfluous and this is
one of those things like the phone calls
that they keep exchanging about his
performance you know what I mean cuz he
never shows up or does anything that has
anything to do with the plot or you know
what I mean I'm just saying so Linda
gets to the house to babysit immed gets
groped by John kerine Richard's the guy
playing Richard and then gets left alone
with this child from hell now
Christopher the kid he's really into
magic tricks and pranks and I will say
I'm I think I'm estimating a good 60 to
70% of this movie's runtime consists of
the kid playing Just seemingly endless
numbers of pranks on this Hess
babysitter woman um and it kind of
includes like a harmless [__] like you
know oh a fake glass of spilled milk on
the floor or jumping out at her from
behind the couch like with an old man
mask on um but then he does like more
extreme gags too like pretending to have
his finger cut off and like faking being
dead like drowned in the pool and [__]
like that now Linda I will say seems to
fall for his tricks like way longer than
maybe a normal person would but
eventually she gets wise and kind of
stops responding to him and at one point
she even tells him that old boy who
cried wolf story like in quite lengthy
detail and I was just like yeah I'm
pretty sure everybody knows this story
can we like speed it up a little bit so
while all of that chicanery is going on
Malcolm uh in who's in the Asylum he's
plotting to bust out of the asylum on
Halloween night to get revenge on the
wife that put him away now to this end
he recruits a fellow inmate to snore
really loud to I guess distract the
staff but then when he puts his plan
into action it turns out that the whole
snoring thing that he asks the guy to do
is completely pointless because all that
happens is like the nurse bends over
Malcolm's bed and Malcolm basically just
strong arms her down onto the mattress
and steals her clothes as well as the
wig she happens to be wearing quite
conveniently and after that there's kind
of a long series of gags involving Peter
Jason as Malcolm wearing you know a
woman's wig and a woman's nurse's
uniform and heading towards his old
family home but eventually he comes
across a couple of bums one of which is
uh berell and kind of threatens to knife
them unless they give him their clothes
you know what I mean now he also stops
to call his old house like several times
from a pay phone like to threaten them
or whatever and the babysitter Linda
starts to think some Maniac is making
prank calls and is going to show up at
the house to killer which you know is
pretty accurate as far as that goes cuz
that's essentially what's going to
happen so Malcolm gets to the house and
breaks in and because we need some extra
like cannon fodder for this supposed
Slasher movie which really has a pretty
low body count you know overall Linda
has this friend named Andrea now Andrea
is played by Jillian Kessner who was
actually Gary graver's wife in real life
might still be actually now that I'm
thinking about it and she was actually
her most famous acting role was playing
fonzi's girlfriend like on one I think a
single episode of Happy Days like in
1977 so this character Andrea she's a
film editor and she agrees to drop by
the house where Linda's babysitting so
she can drop off some footage that she
edited that Linda needs for an acting
audition you know what I mean so Andrea
gets to the house um and Malcolm
mistakes Andrea for his ex-wife Joan
even though the two women look
absolutely nothing alike and then he
stabs the [__] out of her and kills her
while Linda is outside looking for
Christopher after one of his pranks or
something like that he's like out
running around in the yard or whatever
so then the last 15 20 minutes of the
movie is kind of just your standard cat
and mouse Chase through the house with
Malcolm who was was apparently
delusional threatening to kill Linda
because he thinks that she's his ex-wife
Joan and Linda kind of continually
escaping and hiding from him right so at
last after you know several minutes of
this both her and the kid lock
themselves in uh the kids room
Christopher's room but Malcolm busts in
through another door like he did used to
live in this house so he knows the you
know the room had another door to it and
then after that Linda is somehow able to
get Malcolm into the kids like fake uh
Guillotine toy which was kind of
established in like a prank earlier on
in the
movie and then it turns out that Linda
some at some point earlier and off
screen altered it to make it work like a
real one right now it doesn't cut off
Peter Jason's head completely um he just
kind of groans and coughs up some blood
and calls it a day so evidently the
killer has been defeated but no no not
so fast this is an 80 slasher movie kind
of which means that there has to be one
final little twist one little gotcha at
the very end so in this case uh Linda
and Christopher go downstairs so Linda
can call the police but then Christopher
the kid sneaks up behind her with this
huge and apparently real butcher knife
although they kind of leave it ambiguous
maybe it's fake I don't know and the
movie kind of like freeze frames as he's
bringing the blade down on her from
behind so either he's pulling one last
prank which seems unlikely or the movie
saying hey the kids suck just as much as
you thought and was also like maybe a
chip off the crazy old block cuz he's
just as nuts as his dad so I'll be
honest um I'm going to say this is like
not like not really a lost Halloween
classic or anything like that by any
means uh it's very noticeably lowbudget
um a lot of the acting is pretty cringe
uh there's very little Gore and I don't
think there was any nudity in it to
speak of and I will say that despite its
kind of slasher style form format and
setup the kill count really not all that
high uh The Kills themselves not very
bloody or exciting there's also not much
suspense and really not many scares I
mean we know from the beginning like who
the Killer is and what his motivations
are so there isn't really any mystery in
that regard um as I mentioned earlier
there's also kind of way too much time
spent on aspects of the story that don't
really matter like the really tiresome
number of practical jokes that
Christopher plays on the babysitter um
the whole phone calls about aell thing
and there's also a couple scenes where
Andrea the film editor and another woman
who were editing a horror film um and
they show scenes from that horror film
which is horribly cheesy like in this
movie and I'm not really sure why that
was in there and they're just kind of
like talking about how much horror
movies freak them out and all this other
kind of stuff so that really didn't need
to be in there there are also kind of
some attempts at humor that don't really
quite land um although I admit that I
did like chuckle at a couple of lines
here and there so there are some kind of
like funny lines in there but it's not a
comedy by any means but you can tell
they were trying to put humor in it and
a lot of it doesn't really work at least
it didn't work for me I mean that said
though um this is really no worse than
some other 80s cheapies I've seen and is
considerably better than some of those I
mean simply by virtue of all the cool
cameos and I will say that Peter Jason's
performance is like really fun he's like
really unhinged and he's like really
good at it he looks unsettlingly
unsetting unsettlingly like meatloaf in
this movie uh I'm not sure what it was
It was kind of freaking me out a little
bit uh also got to say I enjoyed the
little brief shot of the soundtrack
albums this was also a cameo appearance
soundtrack albums from Maniac and the
howling which were in Christopher's
record collection so I thought that was
kind of neat uh now the movie despite
being called trick-or treats is not real
overtly Halloweeny like Linda does
answer the door to trick-or-treaters a
bunch of times like over the course of
the night so there is like a little bit
of a Halloween vibe to it even though
the plot itself is isn't really as kind
of tied to the holiday as you know like
John Carpenter's Halloween or some of
the newer anthologies which are more way
based around the holiday you know what
I'm saying I mean but if you're a fan of
movies that are set on Halloween or kind
of cheesy slashy slashers in general
like from the 1980s you might want to
give it a look um it does sort of drag
in the second act there aren't a lot of
splashy Gore effects or creative kills
to really like distinguish it from any
of the other you know millions of
slasher movies that came out at in the
era uh it is streaming on shudder at at
least as of this recording so I mean if
you want to add it to your kind of
Halloween night watch list then check it
out and let me know what you think or
let me know if you've seen it or you
know if you really liked it or something
like that I noticed like some of the um
comments like on shutter like after it's
like some people are just like oh this
is my favorite Halloween movie because
it was like nostalgic for them I didn't
really have a nostalgic thing because I
didn't see it back in the'80s so you
know it's it's kind of like middle tier
I guess like slasher movies I've seen
ones a lot worse than this but I've seen
like a lot of way better ones too so
that will do it for this flickers of
here hope you guys enjoyed it please
remember like share subscribe comment
and all of that good stuff and have a
happy Halloween I'll see you on the next
one